hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast where's the screening program
ATT community health care system I am
Judy Oracle a birds and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by labret skaam the
leading social media site for science
professionals and sponsored by roche
diagnostics as a global leader in health
care roche diagnostics offers a broad
portfolio of tools and help healthcare
professor providers in the early
detection prevention diagnosis and
treatment of diseases in molecular
diagnostics the company is driven by a
vision of working with laboratories like
yours to improve the medical value you
offer in microbiology infectious
diseases oncology and genomics roche
diagnostics continues to meet unmet
needs through its investment in research
innovation and scientific excellence
with the goal of supporting your
important role in improving patients
lives before we start there are a few
instructions we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers are welcome to you can
do this by hitting the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today on a better look you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
let us know by clicking on the support
button on the top right or use the Q&A
button we'll make sure we try to resolve
any issues now let's get right to
today's presenter we are proud to
welcome dr. Rodney Arcenas clinical
scientist in microbiology immunology and
molecular pathology consultants of south
broward LLP within memorial healthcare
system dr. arsonist earned a BS with
honors in microbiology from University
of Florida in the spring of nineteen
ninety-seven
he continued his microbiology training
at the University of South Florida
College of Medicine graduating in 2002
with an ms and PhD in medical
microbiology and immunology dr. Arcenas
was then accepted into the clinical
microbiology fellowship program at the
Mayo Clinic in Rochester Minnesota after
completing his fellowship he was hired
in 2004 at lab one incorporated in
lenexa kansas to be the scientific
director of microbiology and immunology
he left lab 1 in 2006 to join me
pathology consultants of south broward
pcs V as their clinical scientist for
microbiology and molecular testing and
has been there since in his time with
pcs V dr. Arcenas has helped to start
being molecular infectious disease
testing service which has grown from a
day shift operation with two medical
technologists eight hours Monday through
Friday to having five full-time and
three part-time medical technologists
with 24-hour shifts monday through
friday and an irradiated one and a half
shifts on weekends he has also helped
spearhead the implementation of a
successful mersa active surveillance
program that started in 2008 dr. are
seen as is board certified as a
diplomate of the american board of
medical microbiology I will now turn it
over to dr. Arcenas for his presentation
well thank you for the introduction and
thank you everyone for joining us today
so as mentioned i will be discussing vs
screening program and in particular our
environment in our setting and kind of
go over the drivers and implementation
and planning and development and some of
the outcome metrics related to our
development and implementation of
immersive screening program so very
briefly some of the objectives will be
discussing today's again understanding
what kind of drove us and to developing
an active surveillance program also
discuss kind of the planning
implementation within a multi hospital
community healthcare system and then
lastly the show
downstream successes of our Mercer
screening program so just a very brief
background about our environment down
here we're located in broward county
which you can see here in south florida
the county colored in red and we're
actually in the lower half of that
county and we're a total of six
hospitals one of which is a children's
hospital in total we have about two
thousand one hundred four beds and it's
a third largest public health care
system in the United States now sort of
drilling down into that South Broward
County what we have here going from left
to right or west to east we have our
hospitals near amar ow located here in
the west and actually about several
miles to the west of that is the
Everglades and so moving east we have
Memorial Hospital West here Pembroke and
then our flagship hospital more regional
hospital that has the same campus our
children's hospital that you would
imagine your children's hospital and
then lastly down here's our lemoore
regional hospital south and that's where
our molecular lab is located and then
actually few go several miles east
that's uh you're at the beach so I'm
just kind of give you an overview of our
in a kind of physical environment and
where I'm molecular web centralized
obviously specimens need to get
delivered in a timely manner and so it's
always a challenge in southbourne
traffic for couriers to get specimens
over here from our Miramar hospital west
and then headed to our molecular
laboratory so yeah it is quite a
challenge and as the crow flies i guess
you can pump this from Middlemore
Hospital over to regional South it's
about 12 14 miles but obviously the
traffic and will be will feel like much
longer so so getting into sort of the
need of the talk when implementing any
kind of infection control program it's
it's good to understand the scope of the
problem you're trying to address and and
so obviously for us today we're going to
discussing more so prevalence and
the sort of start out at sort of a
united states national level kind of
drill down to florida level and then
talk about our specific environment here
so um jarvis at all and i have reference
articles down here at the bottom they
the authors performed kind of a snapshot
study back in two thousand six and then
in 2010 and looking at not only
infection rate but interestingly they
also looked at colonization rate and
these were questionnaires that were
submitted to hospitals within the a pic
membership of the association for
professionals and infection control and
so they they took snapshots at these two
different times and and I have to
apologize that the data here for this
2006 2000 should be reverso in 2006 it
should be 46.3 colonization rate in 2010
it actually showed an increase in
colonization rate at sixty six point
four so keeping that in mind there was
an increase in colonization rate and one
could argue that the that's because the
there's an increase in a number of
institutions performing Mercer screening
compared to the prior year so that's
kind of interesting to show that yes
we're detecting more conversation but is
that because now more institutions are
screening for an Mrs a and then if you
look at infection rate in here you can
see where it's actually the climb in the
merce infection rate again one could
infer that healthcare workers health
care institutions are just more aware of
Mercia and and again implementing not
only screening programs but then
potentially implementing decolonisation
regimens for those that are commercially
colonized and then this last column when
you look at the percent detected with it
or at least less than 14 hours a
hospital admission sort of gives an
indication that most patients are
already presenting to the hospital
colonize reverse and this sort of
coincides with the incident
of or increasing incidence of
community-acquired mrs a and another set
of data to look at and this is from the
cdc and this is actually from 2013 data
that was published just earlier this
year in January CDC put out a national
state health care-associated infections
progress report and so it's another way
of looking at the scope of Mercia and so
this slide can be is kind of busy so
I'll try and go through it and kind of
give the explanations you see here they
murse excuse me CDC correlated this data
basically us number of use hospitals
throughout the u.s. submitted data based
on infection rates and looking at the
catheter excuse me a central line
associated bloodstream infections
catheter-associated UTIs surgical site
infections and then courses the thing to
focus here is Marissa bacteremia and you
can see with the number of hospitals
reporting and they report the data as an
as an SI re as you see here in this last
column and si R stands for standardized
infection ratio so it's a way to
normalize the data so that you can truly
compare from one one year to another one
state to another to get an idea of where
you stand and the lower the SI are the
better you are so generally speaking as
a as as a nation when you look at the
2013's IRS point 92 and you can see
there's a national baseline that was
established in 2011 so we're actually
lower this year which is which is
indicative of it overall efforts towards
being aware of hospital-acquired
infections and Marissa back dream is in
general and then compared to the prior
year 2012-2013 again a five percent
decrease in the SI are however when you
drill down to the state of Florida
obviously there's going to be kind of
more specific numbers and when you look
at and focus on bacteremia you can see
here Florida's
not doing the best job but again it's
sort of indicated by the number of
hospitals at submit data so that there's
a caveat to the data being presented
here but you know it gives us an
indicator of generally speaking how well
your particular state is doing and this
report has all the 50 states in this
document so it's kind of a good idea to
see how you compare with others and see
where and how the state is doing with
regards to hospital part infections and
then another way to look at it is to
look at the impact on the sort of
estimated annual death rate and this is
the awesome CDC data looking at the
antibiotic resistant threats in 2013 as
you can see going down the list to the
content of resistant enterobacteriaceae
multi-drug resistant as you know dr.
from Connors arm is this in Canada the
ESB lvr EES multidrug-resistant
Pseudomonas as well as drug resistant to
MTV seed if they hover around five six
percent annual death rate and then when
you look at methicillin-resistant Staph
aureus see here the estimating hello
death rate approaching fourteen percent
so again mersa being needed a larger
percentage of contributing to the
estimated annual death rate so again
another indication trying to understand
the scope of mrsa and then sort of
drilling down to our institution this is
anti by branding distances mersa that's
been isolated as a result at a clinical
or clinical infection dive not not for
screening so just to give you an idea
the majority of Staph aureus that we
isolate in our microbiology laboratory
is mrs a so again just giving an
indication of kind of a scope of the
problem and I have a ladder slide that
actually shows a point prevalence study
we did and I'll discuss that more into
the planning stages and development
stages that we did but again it's sort
of interesting data just to understand
kind of the national scope and then as
you drill down to your specific
environment now one of the things that
sort of worked its way into kind of
institutional medical practices is
legislation and and these are in
generally speaking these aren't
necessarily a medically based but again
something that in reality we have to
deal with and so this is a number of
states have actually implemented a
legislation and enacted laws saying that
health care institutions need to develop
or establish a mercifully program and
you can see here this is data from
actually less last updated to see down
at the bottom of 2011 so these are the
states and blue are the ones that had
enacted and implemented mersa rose
versus weaning lost so that they're
required to undergo or implementing
mercer screening program the state of
florida at least since back in 2011 and
through today they at least discussed
making it a legislation but i don't
think anything has come to fruition yet
but our healthcare institution does
voluntarily report the our surgical site
infections and other hospital acquired
infections and so it's part of a
initiative from the state to sort of
track these and occupations so again
legislation working its way a pic and
Shay a pic the Association professional
session control and Shay which is the
Society for healthcare epidemiology of
America put out a statement in 2007
basically stating and I have here a
quote from the document position
statement saying that they do not
support legislation to mandate use of
active surveillance former so the area
or any other antimicrobial resistance
pathogen so so again it's up to the
institution and it's each institution is
going to be different has a different
environment so it's hard to put sort of
a blanket legislation
or in practice to really apply to all
institutions because some institutions
may not have them ursa problem or other
infectious disease related problem and
some institutions might it just really
depends and that's something that if
you're seriously considering
implementing some sort of infection
control program that it's important
again to understand the scope of the
problem within your setting so why
scream for mrs am sore that's the kind
of the big question of you know why
didn't you go forward with this and
there's a number of literature articles
editorials suggesting the benefits of
MRSA screening and and then there's on
the sort of the opposite end there's
there's articles and editorials
suggesting a lack of benefit for
immersive screening and one of the
problems and when you read these lurch
articles and editorials is that each
again each institution is going to be
different the patient population with an
inch institution is going to be
different and then also the method of
how your screening whether it be a
culture versus molecular and I think
with any infection control program
there's not really any true case control
studies to really show okay specifically
a particular vegetable measure is the
sole cause or reason why successful seen
on the other end so infection control
it's typically a bundle approach you
have various facets trying to work
together towards a common goal or
program so again it's hard to really
have a true case-control study and I
just put one reference here from the
journal of clinical microbiology the de
screen are not the screen for mrs a and
it's a particularly good article with a
sort of a point-counterpoint one of the
authors is from an institution obviously
that has immersive 3d program in place
and has implemented ensuring success and
then others the other institutions again
they have not implemented mercer
screening and they give
they give very compelling reasons on
both ends so to get into our specific
environment in our planning and
implementation and I show here kind of a
timeline and we really started planning
and developing this back in november two
thousand seven i had attended a
conference are one of our tech control
practitioners had attended a different
conference and we came back and we
shared notes and actually they that's
kind of where this whole inception of
mercy screening in our institution was
sort of born we thought it was a
worthwhile effort and so we started that
initiative and getting firstly
administrative support and in kind of
infectious disease infection control
support to say okay yeah this is going
to be beneficial we think this is going
to be beneficial nurses no it's not so
with something like this it really
requires a top-down effort from the
administration and then it's sort of a
trickles down to the clinical staff
nursing staff I mean go home I mean from
A to Z it really affects the Royal
Institution and so I I highlight here
some of the bullet points that were
important in sort of getting getting the
Planning and Development going and
really when you look at performing the
multi-disciplinary teams it's really
important to involve all the
stakeholders and this is something that
we probably took a lot of time Bobby the
bulk of the planning and development and
just coordinating the efforts between
the different disciplines obviously
laboratory infection control but medical
staff nursing staff administration and
which one of the difficulties we came
across was just with the infectious
disease commissions for the system for
our health care system they they they
obviously saw the benefit they were on
board with us video I'm fair busy
clinicians there
patience they're doing consults and so
they were there they were with us in
spirit but it was hard to really get the
F relevant to really spread the word to
at least clinician the clinician
interaction so it really eventually
became a laboratory and flesh control
kind of spearheaded effort towards
getting this program off the ground and
I mentioned obviously administration
here being important pharmacy was
important because we are in our
educational efforts were that if a mersa
patient or a patient murmurs i colonized
and they would undergo decolonization
regimen and and so so that was key to
get them on board obviously for the
bactroban and chlorhexidine
decolonization one of the educational at
least a couple of educational efforts we
did was bring in speakers from
institutions that have already
implemented mercy screening so it's
always good for our clinicians or
administrative staff to hear from other
outside institutions that they've went
through this process that being actually
had success with the process and so it
was good to hear outside of us the
laboratory in tight control telling
administration medical staff to hear
this outside person non non healthcare
system person tell their story tell
their successes tell their challenges so
that we can best adapt immersive
screening program to fit our institution
and then it goes without saying with the
patient bed control obviously the
reflection possible it's a semi-private
room a facility and so the placement of
patients is needs to be orchestrated
carefully just because infection control
did not want to go work a merciful
colonized patient with a non merci
economize patients so there's a that
required a certain amount of effort
there thankfully our other institutions
are all private rooms or the
we didn't have that issue to deal with
as we do here are flattery possible i T
is key here just because in the
laboratory we're in the business of
information delivery and so it's
important to get results at and timely
manner and so that infest control
medical staff mercy death is aware and
can take the appropriate measures then
that would be contact precautions and
then in starting the decolonization
regimen initially in the planning
development arm fresh control and
medical staff one at the laboratory to
call on all our positives to the floor
is essentially treating it as a critical
value which we felt our staff is not
would not be the best use of their time
I mean we need our medical technologists
to be medical technologist and and at
the time the health care system had a
few months before that had implemented
ferredoxin if you're not familiar with
their doc it's a relational database
that marries microbiology laboratory
data with pharmacy and with infection
control so and the neat thing about the
Thera doc is that the end users infect
control nursing clinicians can customize
alerts so that infection growth and set
up okay when immersive screening result
comes back positive I want to be alerted
and that's either by email or can done
by page so at least they're
automatically alerted and that sort of
eliminates the requirement by the
technologies and it really it's done in
a more timely manner than it could be
done by a person try and find someone so
so that's good and so now what we have
is is important to have that thorough
doc implementation in place so we
definitely took advantage of that so
next as they say a picture is worth a
thousand words and so what we love we
presented to our administration is that
okay because we don't have a Mercer
program in place this is what we're
capturing as far as patients with a
clinical mersin
action now knowing what worse
accommodation the implications with that
we felt we presented their
administration that they were only
getting the tip of the iceberg what
about all those patients that are just
mercial colonized and not overtly from
have a clinical infection so this was
kind of the idea of identifying these
patients so that they can so that
appropriate precautions can be
implemented decolonization and they
don't service was reservoirs of
infection within our healthcare
institution and there was a study in
clinical infectious diseases in 2004
that stated that about thirty percent of
those that are compromised with MRSA
that are hospitalized actually end up
with an infection with their own
colonizing versus strain so again the
indications is preventing and
identifying reservoirs of Mercia
colonization and then was preventing a
murse infection in these patients that
immersive colonize so to get into kind
of our strategy for mercy screening what
we have oh there's kind of two schools
of thought you can go Universal route
and screen everyone that that comes in
two and get submitted to your healthcare
institution you can also selectively
target high-risk patient screening and
you didn't know which way to go
logistically and probably for the sake
of me the laboratory staff we kind of
wanted to avoid the universal screening
just because of we be testing everyone
but we really needed to know which way
to go and so that's where point
prevalence studies came in and so what
we did was a one-day snapshot within our
healthcare institution we looked and
took an anterior near swab of all of our
impatience as long as they consented and
we had almost ninety nine percent
consent that
so we got a good representation of the
impatience in our health care system
when we found that nine percent of our
in patients are immersed the colonized
and when we drill down and looked at
those mersa colonized patients we found
that all those fit in our high-risk
category and so just to define where our
high-risk category is we we we took a
mix of what we've seen at other
healthcare institutions that have
already implemented a merger screening
program and then we took some of the
what a pic considers high-risk patients
so we came up with this list and so as
you can see critical care admissions or
transfers or whether they're admitted
directly the ICU or they may be on the
general floor and if they haven't been
screened yet they're going to be
screened before they as a or as they
enter the ICU Ward's admissions for
long-term care facilities patients who
have previously tested mercer positive
and that's colonization or hadn't
documented mercy infection dialysis
patients and chronic medial renal
failure patients admissions with skin
and soft tissue infections and then just
those frequent flyers that seem to be
proud showing up with increased
frequency to our healthcare institutions
additionally we also implemented mercer
screening as part of a pre-surgical work
up when patients come in usually five to
seven days before their procedure is
scheduled along with the normal routine
blood work lab work they will get an
anterior near swab and get tested for
mercy colonization and again if positive
its communicated back to them and the
scripts game for them to go to the
pharmacy to get a the decolonization
regimen of the Clark city and bacteria
and so by the time they show up to or
for that procedure they should be
decolonized and at least protected for
that time during the procedure so
getting into at least the when you talk
about what molecular screening or mercy
meaning we did evaluate molecular versus
a chrome auger which is a its culture
media but it if it's mrs a and then it
shows up a particular color so it's
somewhat eliminates some of the post
testing that you need you to confirm
although as I'm sure many of you know is
the chrome Walker's aren't completely
one hundred percent specific and there
are some issues and false positives so I
think one of the big limitations for us
of why we did not go with culture is
just because of the time issue of
getting result out in 18 to 24 hours at
least 24 culture wrong with a screening
test right now we're getting results out
in about 11 12 hours actually speed me
12 to 14 hours so so I'll talk more
about our turnaround time later on and I
mentioned the decolonization regimen and
here is the specific one that we use we
actually got from another house key
institutions those with a back term an
ointment in the mayor's times daily and
then chlorhexidine battle writedowns
depending on how inventory the patient
being so the total decolonization
regimen is about seven days and then
just revisiting the timeline so again
the timeline for the Planning
development beginning in november two
thousand seven and then we actually went
live october two thousand eight one of
the difficulties with going live in
october in parallel we were molecular
lab was actually moving to make
different lavatory just for sake of
space it was bigger space and so we
actually ended up moving September 2008
and into our laboratory new laboratory
at the time and so we had about a month
to really get everything set up
validated and ready to go and thankfully
with the IT in our lab staff we were
able to go live and is actually mid
october two thousand eight we decided to
go hospital by hospital versus a big
bang approach as i mentioned earlier in
the introduction slides you saw her big
our healthcare institution is and we
felt doing life with a smaller hospital
we can work out the kinks and
operational things that and it's
impossible to anticipate all those
things in the pre a pre go live stage
and so it was good at least start small
get her feet wet so to speak work out
the kinks and then and then expand and
you can see the timeline of when we went
live with various hospitals and
ultimately going ride may 2009 took
about a good six months seven months to
go live with the entire health care
system on board so just very lastly to
get into some of the Mercer screening
outcomes of metrics again we can it's
good for our administration and good for
us to show that we're having a positive
benefit on the patient side of things
and and so so so here's some of the data
and I i have here 16 17 hour turnaround
time and that was actually early this
year before we had three shifts and now
with the three shifts were able to get a
result about 1214 hours and so that's
from time to collection to time to
result and we usually have two runs per
day so we have a run starting around
midday and then and then usually run on
our third shift so again we're able to
at least get a turnaround time that
satisfactory for our infection control
practitioners again with thier doc they
automatically get alerted so it really
takes at that time if we were to call
all those positive results and then I
mentioned the presurgical screenings
usually about five to seven days prior
to schedule procedures so we definitely
get those results out a timely manner so
that the clinician can implement them
the appropriate decolonization protocol
and then here's looking at our at least
experience from the laboratory so in the
orange bars represent our versus
screaming volumes that we've
seen throughout the years through the
end of 2014 and then the blue bars
represent the positivity rate so you can
see here with the volumes increasing
throughout the years here and we've
noticed I mean in general increase
patient population showing up at our
healthcare institutions so as time has
gone on we've had more patients coming
in and that's really led to our increase
in volumes again the positivity rate you
can see here and excuse me the next
slide I actually had positivity rate so
this is sort of capturing the latter
half of in 2008 and 2009 so that's sort
of combined here in that first column
and you can see with our Mercer rate
sort of declining over time and it's
sort of it's remained steady around the
fourteen fifteen percent so this is what
we're seeing it's hard to say what this
means as far as our efforts in
identifying these were stationed and
County of decolonization but at least
it's sort of an interesting observation
to show a decline immersive colonization
of course one of the big things that our
finance people wanted to see was you
know what's what's this costing the
healthcare system and I should mention
ahead of time that the patient is not
charged for any of this testing so the
healthcare system felt this was a
patient safety initiative something that
the healthcare system is going to eat
the cost for and we actually are part of
our education to the patient is also we
prepared pamphlets for the patient and
patient families where it explains what
we're doing why we're doing it and and
so that they know that this is something
that the healthcare system is is
ultimately covering for at least for the
Mercer screening so in the yellow bars
is the lab testing and that obviously is
going to be the majority cost just
because of the testing reagents and so
this is really only considering the test
the test reagents tech time is not
included
obviously our texts are doing other
assays so it's harder I was would have
been hard to at least break out that
time so this is really just looking at
reagents the blue bars represent the
pharmacy costs of the cost of the
decolonization regimen and then the
green line here I have as the total cost
a lab plus pharmacy and you can see as
we expect with volumes increasing the
cost of the program has increased with
regards to lab and pharmacy I did not
include infection control the personal
protective equipment required for
contact precautions just because these
patients sometimes there's another
reason why they they are under contact
precautions and it may not necessarily
be for MRSA in the beginning so it's
hard to account for that and also
there's multiple times that healthcare
workers go into a patient's room and
they put on and take off these personal
protective equipment so I did not
include that just to make it relatively
easy to come up with a kind of a
guesstimated kind of laboratory pharmacy
costs and so the next slide here showing
in the blue line showing the decline in
the number of Mercy Hospital choir
infection so number two thousand eight
we weren't completely live really live
only the writer the latter quarter of
the year so we get a documented 184
Mercer hospital are infections and see
over time going to 2014 we had 29
hospital or infections and so again
showing a decline in mercy hospital
acquired infections but then also we
wanted to put a dollar figure and they
saw our infection control worked with
our finance people to come up with okay
what's it cost the health care system to
to care for a mrsa h AI or hospital
acquired infection so they came up with
about ten thousand dollars per infection
and if you look in the literature
alone this 9000 number is a relatively
low number we've seen or I've seen
numbers as high as 27,000 35,000 as the
excess cost of my health care solution
provides for caring for Marissa patient
that has had versa hae so but regardless
here's the numbers that were calculated
so basically 180 for Marissa a che is x
9000 449 you can't that's how i came up
with these numbers here you can see over
time again less and less expense for
mrsa a che is and so this was something
that a arguments upper administration
and our finance people saw our benefit
now one of the things in trying to its
concepts for our finance people to get
used to is that cost avoidance so what
are we avoiding spending and it's hard
for it was hard for them to sort of
grasp this concept just because it's not
a specific fine item in a budget it's
something that we didn't spend so one of
the big assumptions here if you look for
2008 here again the this blue blue bars
represent oh the cost that the health
care system is is spending to care for
marissa HDI and the assumption here is
that if we did not have a mrsa screening
program in 2009 through 2014 that i made
the assumption that okay we would have
184 versa a che is across the board so
again that's a big assumption but if we
didn't have Marshall screening program
again looking at the cost of avoidance
in the orange bars so again this is what
we avoid it's potentially avoided
spending for Amercia h AI and so again
going from 415,000 in 2009 auto right
two of these estimated for 2014 and cost
avoidance of 1.4 million dollars so
again it gave administration and finance
or an idea of what we avoided spending
again
talking with your finance people it's
good to keep that communication open
because obviously they they speak a
different language than lab and it's
always good to I can equip them and show
that we're trying to kind of can explain
the concepts and not only you know it's
a two-way street so it was it was it was
good at least have those discussions
with them but again they're starting to
get the idea of cost avoidance because
we've used that term and other
laboratory testing we brought in so
again good to establish that
relationship with your findings folks so
I apologize i doing dealing with some
technical difficulties um so in this in
this slide here where I put together the
cost of the what we were spending you
know down here 2008-2009 as far as the
blue bars again the orange bars up here
up top represent the cost avoidance that
we estimated and in gray here is where i
put the cost of the MERS of the program
of the pharmacy and laboratories you can
see perhaps in the beginning we are
spending 1.3 million 1.3 million plus
the 343,000 again exceeding the cost of
rodents but as time goes on you can see
here with 518,000 plus 2 204,000 again
made probably closer to eight hundred
thousand again cost avoiding here 1.4
million dollars so it gives us an idea
of where we stand us from a financial
perspective again not a true cost
analysis but at least give us an idea of
kind of the benefit we saw on the
climate versa a che is and then the fine
from a financial perspective as well
so I in to summarize all those kind of
charts I showed we saw an eighty-four
percent decline in merca h AI is from
2008 to 2014 again adding up those
orange bars in the cost of avoidance
assumptions of 6.5 million dollars that
cost avoided and so again an estimation
there but gives gives administration
something tangible to kind of hold on to
and identify with and and something that
we feel that our administration is proud
of to implement a patient safety
initiative being a public health care
institution everything do is sort of
them and I feel like we're in a fishbowl
and everyone can see what we do so it's
good to show some benefit to bringing in
and spending the money on testing and
expenses for immersive screening program
the show the benefits on the other end
so I just want to close out that you
know with merciless screening and really
any inflection tral initiative it's a
multi-disciplinary effort not only
considering the pre-analytical steps and
from collecting the sample identifying
the patient performing the test getting
the positive result alert out but then
it starts a trigger or a sort of a
downstream effect of getting the
clinicians identified or notified that
the you know the patient is immersive
colonized if I control gates of oral
pharmacy nursing and then also a patient
discharge environmental services so you
can see where there's a downstream
effect and it's a really a
multidisciplinary effort to get to get
the mercial screening program off off
the ground here they in you know I've
heard the statistic where laboratory
testing in general is about three
percent of the healthcare dollar yet
clinicians and other medical decisions
seventy percent of those decisions are
based off of laboratory data so the
laboratory certainly keep
art but we need all the pieces working
together in order to show any kind of
success so thank you for joining me and
and I will now take any questions thank
you okay so we have some questions
coming in in the queue a box I'll just
kind of read these up says here after
this one of the first question after the
seven day regimen of treatment for mr
save you keep your patience and
isolation so yeah yes we do just because
they've been identified and typically
our patients are average like this thing
is making four or five days so typically
they're released and once they're
discharged they're they're told to
maintain and complete the regimen of
course once they're outside the system
is hard to police that but at least we
do try and keep in mice elation usually
if they're going to be in longer than
seven days there's usually something
some other underlying disease or reason
why they're still in house so again we
just sort of keep that isolation going
but the second question when I see
that's coming across what Marcel
molecular test methods have you news or
are using so we did start out with a lab
develop tests back in two thousand eight
so it was a it was a test that
identified staph aureus from the other
coagulase-negative staff so is a
molecular method and then any staph
aureus that was identified we actually
ran those samples or they were reflex to
the gene Xpert mersa SI in 2008 we
actually were running that for a while
and then the ASR or lab developed SPG
was developed on the Roche lightcycler
we then migrated over to the roach mersa
advanced as they got their mrsa SI fda
approved so we were running that for a
while again with the volumes I there was
a front-end step that
processes that that required a lot of
manual steps or I would say a lot of
mimesis but it was manually done by the
text where they had to break off the
swab into a sort of a licensed buffer
tube and then preparation of pcr master
mix and so with our volumes it got to be
a little bit burdensome for our text and
so we actually then did migrate over to
me d max and which is what we're
currently using and the good thing is
that medium axis is semi automated so
you load the reagents you load the
patient samples it there you do have to
break off aslam into a MRSA tune that
goes on to the instrument once you load
the instrument with your agents and
samples it does the extractions it does
as well as the pcr and then gives you
the amplification or it gives you the
final results so at least you have a
allows less hands-on time by our text so
they can do other more critical things
and there are a number of other versa
assays out there that may benefit you
and I mentioned earlier we didn't
evaluate the kolmogorov again with a
time issue of waiting that 18 24 hours
we felt that turnaround time with a
molecular method would serve our
clinicians infecting infection control
better so next question do we need to
make it mandatory for every patient to
be screened for mercy colonization
before major surgeries well it's again
it's it's up to the healthcare
institution it's to really determine if
MRSA is a huge problem in your
institution and you're seeing perhaps a
high rate of surgical site infections
before your surgery is I think that's
something you'll have to address
internally to really see okay if we
implement something and we prevent
versus infections could this be a means
of doing that by implementing immersive
screening program so you'll it's hard to
say without knowing the sort of
nitty-gritty details about your
particular
tution so it's something you have to
look at and dress next question is do
you check Staph aureus methicillin
sensitive collec- staff and
methicillin-resistant collec- staff so
right now no we do not that's something
that we've been looking at and actually
so again I don't think it currently at
least in the u.s. there's no limit to my
knowledge FDA professor things that do
separate collec- staff meth storm's
isn't left so insensitive there are
assays that will separate
methicillin-resistant Staph aureus from
methicillin sensitive staffers and so we
are initially kind of looking at fat
product just because staff for is
whether it's mrs a or m SS a methadone
sensitivity can be significant or not in
a patient as well so we're kind of
looking at that route we have to move to
that sa yet so again something that
we're looking at a question comes with
the what's the current library agent
cost for ed max MRSA I don't have those
specific cost numbers the cost numbers
that i showed incorporated those three
assays i mentioned that we migrated to
and from so i will have my email address
available afterwards so perhaps we can
talk more offline and about the general
numbers with that let's see this next
question coming in did you differentiate
the hospital part mr say from the
patients who had mercer prior to their
hospital visit and i can't see the rest
of the question but uh and how was I'll
repeat the question so did you
differentiate the hospital park mrs de
from the patients who had mrs a prior to
the hospital visit and how was this done
so no we did not differentiate the
hospital acquired versa
and I guess I may be a little confused
as to what in reference does that mean
what patients that were coming in and
then we identified them are infection
control tracks the h.a eyes or hospital
prior infection so hospital acquired mr
essays so they follow that those numbers
I'm sure they have the Merse infections
that came in from the community that
were not considered an h AI so they have
those numbers so that was really a
fishing for a question that I can
certainly find out the answers for them
if again I think my contact information
would be available so that you can
contact me off Ryan I can try to find
the answers to your question um the next
question is it any experimental studies
on the phage therapy for mrs a and i
have not seen any and that's an
interesting concept i again not having
specifically looked in detail to any
kind of therapeutic use of
bacteriophages for mrs a but certainly
certainly an interesting question
apologize don't have a good answer for
that and then lastly or at least this
last question i have is can a vaccine be
developed to prevent mrs a if i guess
you can develop a vaccine to almost any
pathogen i guess the question is how do
you deal with the normal flora because
individuals can be colonized with mrsa
and not you not coming down with the
clinical infection they just are
colonized and there's actually if you
there's an article that I don't have the
immediate references on in my head but I
knew they do talk about patients can be
intermittent colonizers they can be
persistent colonizers and then some
patients actually are seemingly
resistant to Mercer colonization so that
there's an interesting microcosm of
of looking at the host factors and how
people can be those three categories of
persistent intermittent or sort of
resistant to colonization I would it be
hard for a vaccine that target that's
just because it can be normal flora and
sort of survives happily and it's sort
of along for the ride and with in-house
patients so again it's it's hard to say
for sure how effective a vaccine would
be but again I haven't looked at those
in detail about that next question I
have one would be on your most wanted
improvement list for current mersin
molecular test methods perhaps this
could be taken offline it seems to be a
more detailed question but I guess you
know one of the things with merciless
PCR testing in general is just trying to
take an account of all the more so types
there are as we know there's the MEK a
which is the genetic element responsible
for methicillin resistance and there's
different mech elements and one of the
you know advantages resolved with the BB
max is that it can detect mexi which
currently in the u.s. is not a very high
prevalence but at least it's been
reported in Europe and now with the
world become smaller because of air
travel and being able to go from one
place to another within within a day
it's certainly bound to show up in us
sometime so again I think vendors need
to be aware of all the different mech
types out there different elements for
mrs a genetic elements and just be aware
that because any genetic elements that
were mutations observed can adversely
affect the performance of the assay is
just because primers and pros are go
developed to be specific for a certain
gene sequence of any of those jeans or
nucleotides are mutated again potential
needing to subpar performance or even
resulting in a false negative so against
something to be aware about I see that
there's no questions or further
questions so I guess I just want to
thank the audience um and again by my
contact information should be made
available so that you know if any other
questions come up or some of the
questions that we better off to take
better able to talk to take off line and
I could help you answer those questions
thank you everyone again for joining us
today and I turn it back to Junie I
would like to thank dr. Arcenas for his
presentation I would also like to thank
our sponsor roche diagnostics for making
it possible to bring this priest